Can a person ever overuse the RIFE machine?
I've had TINITUS for 55 years,
possibly as a result of a wish-wip lash
from a sledding incident, and have been using
the TINITUS program since February 1st.
I'm starting to have redness and heat spots on my face
in the tops of my feet.
I'm not sure if these symptoms are a result
of the RIFE program, but this is the only change
I've implemented recently.
I have been using this too much.
It is an all-night program, seven, eight-hour program.
Also the goal of the TINITUS program
is to kill possible parasites of the brain
or to store a fire up sedapses in the brain cells.
So this person is talking about a true RIFE program
for TINITUS.
So the true RIFE program for TINITUS,
I personally didn't write.
So I honestly don't know what's in that program.
If it is a parasite frequencies or not,
I haven't looked at that program for years.
So I don't know if it doesn't have any headings,
I have no idea what the frequencies are.
Remember, every program in your RIFE folder
is a set of different frequencies
that the software is telling to run.
And so it depends on what frequencies are in there.
So if they are kill frequencies,
so if they're bacterial frequencies
or lime frequencies or parasite frequencies,
if they are, yes, you could be running the RIFE too much.
So remember, if you kill too quickly,
if you kill a pathogen too quickly,
a parasite, a bacteria, or even a virus too quickly,
you can, you will liberate endotoxins
that your liver has to get out.
And if you do kill too quickly,
you could overwhelm to your liver detox pathways.
That is the definition of a herximer reaction.
If there are kill programs in that program
that are killing gram-negative bacteria,
you will be liberating lipopolysaccharides,
which would definitely give you a herximer reaction.
So I don't know what's in that program.
So yes, you could be killing too much with that.
That's why I say, you think you have lime disease,
so you're gonna run some lime programs.
You gotta go really slow,
or you could overwhelm your detox pathways
or you could give yourself a herximer reaction.
So you have to be very careful with that.
So honestly, I did not write that program for tonight
so I don't know what's in it.
So I would say, yes, you gotta be careful.
Back off, maybe do some detox, do some foot baths,
do some coffee enemas, other things like that
to help your body detox hot packs over your liver,
to help your body detoxify.